Hello everybody, welcome back to The Wolf of Marguerite's
Day, episode 2.
Chapter 2?
Are they called chapters or episodes?
Wait, no, there are many chapters inside.
And they are...
Wait, they are chapter...
No, sorry, there are episodes and there are chapters inside.
Yes, good morning!
Or, oh, well, it's morning for me as I am recording this,
but good time zone to you.
Wherever you are and whatever time it is that you are
watching this, I hope you are excited, ready for...
Wait, episode 2?
Oh, can you tell?
I haven't had my coffee.
Actually, I don't know what I'm saying.
I don't know what I'm saying.
It's fine.
We are back with a Bigby and our very cool mystery.
I'm trying to still decide what kind of vibe I want to give
Bigby.
You know, like, on the one hand, I, like, sympathize with
him because he is, like, you know, the big bad wolf.
But he clearly wants to be, like, reformed, right?
He doesn't want everybody to think he's the big bad wolf.
But on the same time, I kind of want to be like, well, if
everybody already hates me, why don't we be the bad cop?
But so we could kind of have like a bad cop, good cop, bad
cop thing going on.
Whatever I feel like.
What are some of these are the extras, I'm assuming.
Yeah, the book of fables.
Oh, wait, what is this guy?
What the heck is a Grendel?
Grendel just wants to be left alone in the old days he
terrors.
Norse meat hauls.
Interesting.
Who are you supposed to- Holly?
She's just a troll.
And then tweedle-dee and tweedle-dee.
The tweedles.
Oh.
I guess that's what Prince Lawrence would have looked like
if we had seen him alive.
Um, but he- Okay, so he did have a stab wound.
We saw that from the knife on the ground.
It seems like the guy wouldn't have made it.
Maybe?
I don't know.
Oops.
I just wanted to see Mr. Toad.
Oh, Mondays.
Okay, so Mondays are the people that are not magical people.
Got it.
The farm.
It looks kind of nice.
Oh, there's...
Oh, my big head is blocking it.
But there's like the...
Oh, what was that?
What was that?
is that fable of the lady that lives in the shoe.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, that's that.
Fable town.
Bufkin.
Bufkin, Bufkin.
Winged monkey from the land of Oz.
Now does Oz count as a fable?
I feel like we're stretching it a bit, but sure, whatever,
sure, sure.
Yeah, Mr. Toad.
This guy sucks.
Okay, okay.
Wait, who is this?
Oh, that's a blue beard.
Oh, wait, no, no, I don't want to read that.
I don't want to read it.
Sorry.
And that's us.
Begoby.
No, this is...
What?
Never mind.
We're in the... we're in their toy.
Whatever.
Don't look at it.
No, no spoilers.
Anyway, let's get into...
Episode 2!
Let's go!
Okay.
oh episode two smoke and mirrors now there was this i
believe it was this guy that a bunch of people were saying
like rather at the end of the thing it said oh a certain
number of players believe it's this guy but i don't think
i've maybe maybe if you went to prince lawrence you thought
it you you were able to learn about this guy maybe like if
you were able to talk to prince lawrence before he passed
away maybe okay mr toad do something big b before he
completely tears up the place whoa whoa whoa hey you've got
something on your face fuck are you talking
Ex- Ex- You're not as bad as everyone says you are.
Oh, Fiss.
Please, Big Beast.
I learned about her favor.
Promise me you won't tell Beast you saw me.
Look, whatever it is, it's between you and Beast.
I'm such a liar.
I'm such a troublemaker.
It's not what you might be thinking.
But what is she up to?
What are you up to, P?
Have you seen my wife?
Have you seen Beauty?
I'm such a liar.
Come with me.
Oh, Snow White.
Oh, by the way, I'm eating some oatmeal.
Don't interrupt me, Miss Snow.
You asked me a question.
Don't change the subject.
You are to plead for this unpleasantness, Miss Snow.
No, I'm D.
He's dumb.
Yeah, I kind of messed that one up.
If he ever got back to me, if he ever thought you knew,
well, Miss White, he'd come back and kill one.
He'd come back and kill my boy.
Well, he's not here.
Holly, you're out of paper.
He's not here immediately cuts to him.
I really don't think it's him though.
I didn't do it.
It'd be too easy.
I got a hundred bucks for the first bloke that could tell me
something about a girl name.
Like I was, Grimble was literally crying on the floor.
Oh, it's like a little out of order, you know?
Big bacon.
Worse off than they've ever been.
not true right we've had it worse but not by much oh snow
why i wonder if there was a way i could have protected her
probably not right she shouldn't have left i think it's the
mayor i think that guy sucks i don't know i have no idea oh
this is uh oh my gosh cinema wow the lighting and everything
is so good.
Oh, poor guy.
The one person that was like nice to him and liked him.
Oh.
Snowfly.
And he liked her.
You're making this more difficult than it has to be.
If you just cooperate and answer the questions, you can go
home.
Maybe get some sleep.
Huffs and puffs?
How are you feeling?
I know it's been a long night for you.
You look like you could use some rest.
I'm hunky-dory.
Thanks for asking.
There's no need to get aggressive.
I'm trying to help you.
Why am I being questioned?
Well, I guess...
I know what you must be going through.
Really.
I do.
But I could use your cooperation.
You don't know who did...
You don't know anything.
Yeah.
If you did, you wouldn't be sitting here talking to me.
to me you'd be talking to the piece of shit that did this
yeah well you stonewalling me like this isn't helping either
of us so why don't you cut the shit and i'm getting i'm
doing the same thing that everybody else does to me that i
get mad about i'm being a little i'm being uh uh in
cooperative you big b little little baby what is it with you
cops always trying to empathize Oh, she's like a normie.
Oh, sorry, the Monday, right?
Do you?
Do you fucking know?
Have you had a friend killed and their head left at your
fucking doorstep?
Actually, I have.
No, it's just imagine.
No, I didn't think so.
I, oh, oh my gosh.
I'd be like, oh my gosh, what if Vicky pranked me like that
one day?
Your nose is bleeding.
That'd be crazy.
Why?
Hurry.
Yeah, I'm not even gonna say anything.
What do you say to that?
What?
I'm detective Branigan.
Okay
She could?
Please Please Okay, maybe she does look crazy What is going
on?
Everybody left.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Oh, no, they're not- Make it stop, please They're all like
getting...
What the heck?
We have to go now.
Oh, yeah.
What did you do to her?
She'll be fine.
It's just a memory wipe spell.
Very expensive, but it works.
The whole station will forget the last 24 hours and
everything they saw at the woodlands.
I guess that's good, right?
I'll hurry up.
phone is ringing um maybe you should take that though right
I don't know wait maybe you should take the the photo of the
head and everything so that they aren't like well where's
that yeah good thinking good and maybe her notes no okay
just me sure only I'm thinking of you know
I wonder if he's going to be nicer to us because probably
not.
Because Snow White was his assistant.
This doesn't change anything.
We could ignore him.
I don't want to thank him.
Let's ignore him.
I'm choosing silence.
Crane noticed your silence.
We, um, we found Tweedle Dee chained up to a post that was
your doing, correct?
Oh, dang, I forgot about that guy.
Oops.
Well, I don't know why you detained him.
Dee was at the trip trap when Snow was left at the
Woodlands, so he couldn't possibly be involved in this
mayhem.
You don't, okay, people, like, he's working for somebody.
He's working for somebody.
And whoever it is wants him snooping around every crime
scene I've looked at.
That doesn't necessarily mean they're involved in the
murders.
They're involved somehow, but they know...
You're covering for them.
I don't remember those guys' name.
I'm going to say Iroquois, but I know that's not it.
I know what you're thinking, Big B.
Actually, you could put a bandana on Big B and...
It's been a wonderful night in the slice of morning.
And I already miss her too.
Aww.
I mean, he is a jerk, but...
One of us dies.
Now, for it to be snow, I've never been good with these
sorts of things.
You don't really care.
It's hard, yeah.
It's hard.
Oh.
We have to get it, yeah, we have to get him to kind of
sympathize with us too.
I know.
We had a beginning, a middle, and an end.
But ever since we moved to this awful city, everything's
gotten so confused.
I'm confused.
Did she, um, give any indication to what she was thinking?
You saw her last, I mean.
Uh...
I don't know why, but I'd like to know that she was...
I guess fine, I suppose.
She told me to be careful.
She just told me to be careful.
She was always...
I mean, I could say that she wanted to change things, but...
Yeah.
I don't know how he was...
would respond to that I don't know what else to say big B we
have to have to put an end to this it's been two murders in
as many days we don't unearth our culprit and soon there
will likely be another on our doorstep tonight it's scary
they're also targeting ladies for miss white I got it hey
don't be mad I mean a basement Woodland luxury apartment
that's not a very good answer.
Wait, that's a blue beard.
He's literally under our house It will make things a lot
less painful for you in theory.
Oh, were you planning on using that?
I just thought you really liked rubbing your little sword
Oh, what the hell do you think you're doing?
Hello, Ichabod.
Oh, Ichabod Blue beard I was just so we don't trust this guy
clear.
I guess you were supposed to wait for us to get back I told
you if you want to be involved you will do things my way no
violence he works for us but ish whatever you say Yikabad
what is his relation I thought he was like some gangster
mastermind I want answers D oh goody I thought you wanted
questions and I was having so much trouble thinking of any
good ones though I'd settled on how's your head you see what
I've been dealing with what you're going to do about you're
funny you're real funny you have a sense of yeah i hope that
means you're willing to cooperate snow white is dead look i
didn't kill anyone and i'm supposed to just believe you you
were with me when it happened dummy oh we don't know
actually i mean he came in kind of late no sounds like a
personal problem this is ridiculous why were you at he's got
more Faiths.
You know I saw you at Faith's apartment.
What were you doing there?
Girls got air conditioning.
You can't imagine what it's like living in a little shithole
with no air.
I'm not messing around.
We're not gonna- I'm not fucking around here, Dee.
Yeah.
All right, Dee.
Let's get to know each other.
We're angry because our crush died.
Oh, what am I doing?
Show the photo.
Yeah.
You can help us?
Or Snow was murdered?
This could be you.
If you don't tell me who did this, I'll make sure you end up
the same way.
Dead on your doorstep.
Got it?
I told you, I didn't kill her, and I don't know who's.
did just tell me what you were doing at faith's apartment
look big bean we're not on opposite sides here my brother
and i are trying to get to the bottom of things you got to
talk him as you yeah but your brother oh where was he last
night yeah exactly say he could have been anywhere take your
best guess he didn't do it if that's what you're thinking
then where is he yeah no i'm not sending you after my
brother look i answered your question can i get my stuff
back now what did you find on it oh uh nothing of
consequence really just dumping it out oh we got a cigar are
you done yet i'm getting old we got a lot of cash and some
whiskey this was in his I could punch you.
Anyone can see this isn't working.
It's time to try a different tactic.
Come on.
What is it now, Big B?
Uh, cooperate and you can go.
Where's your brother?
Oh my gosh, hold on.
I'm thinking.
Where's your brother?
I'll ask again.
Where is he?
He's right behind you.
Okay.
I'm going to smoke a cigar.
I know you would...
I'm saving that for what a rainy day I could burn him I'm
gonna blow the smoke what's the point of this we're pissing
him off so he talks more real nice so where's your brother
look mate I'd like to help I would but I can't tell you
where he is oh last time I saw him we split up and I went to
find faith I don't know where he is now but what did you
went to find it was faith something what her apartment I
went to her apartment that's no secret you saw me yeah
there's more to it you said you were trying to find
something yeah exactly all right D since you never answered
my first question what did you want from yeah that's what
I've been wanting to know sorry I can't help you I'm not
saying any more about it mister mister i'm taking your cash
you always carry this much cash i've got a lot of laundry to
do this week what's it to you pocketing it i'm declaring a
tax on uncooperative troublemakers
he was a proud of you you'll need to account for that you
can't just there are procedures to be followed we'll talk
about it later procedures go out the window when two people
are decapitated yeah what did you want girl like her sweet
you think that girl was sweet she was a fucking thief
fucking sweet what did she steal things but that ain't one
of them yeah what did she steal i don't know just some dumb
thing my boss was after oh your boss whoopsie let's talk
about your boss So, he's not working for a blue bear.
What if we get him drunk?
You just carry this around.
Always handy that way.
Let's offer him a drink.
He does not approve.
I couldn't hurt, I guess.
Yeah, if we get him drunk, he might be talking, right?
Nope.
Why don't you just tell me who you're working for?
Yeah, who are you working for?
Look, you're not a bad guy, despite what Beauty says about
you.
At least you're not a total bastard anyway.
But I just can't give you that information.
What is Beauty saying about me?
There's no way Beauty would associate with a scumbag like
you.
What's wrong with me?
You're telling me I ain't pretty enough.
Yeah, let him talk.
Let him talk.
Yeah, we're real close.
I thought this was supposed to be a murder investigation,
but you're treating this guy like a fucking house guest
Bluebeard and not getting any answers from him this way.
Snow White is dead one of us and you're going to let this
Ignorant shit walk out of here in one piece.
Hey, hey.
I'm working on it.
I'll show you how it's done.
Oh, yeah Punch him.
What the fuck?
What do you think you're doing?
Teaching him a lesson.
Now pay attention.
Yeah in yourself I'm just gonna watch that's not what I did
oh that's not what I did at all wait a second I just
couldn't stand there well I'm not gonna lose now
whoops no wait what what's going on
Huh?
What?
Snow.
No.
What?
It's gotta be some magic, no?
Unless it was a magic disguising her head?
Huh?
It's so funny too because earlier I was like, in my head I
was thinking, I was like, there's like, I mean they're
magical beings, right?
There must be some way she comes back or something.
But then I was like, no, that's like, you know.
Wait a second!
Huh?
What are you working on?
It's gotta be somebody in disguise.
We'll test her.
Episode 2, Smoke and the Mirrors.
Because surely they would have done some sort of test on the
head.
This guy's still asleep.
this is why we have people getting murdered what is going on
here what the hell was going on down there Big B I have many
questions for you abusing a prisoner like that I thought you
could control yourself I thought you were dead I thought you
were dead Snow and that makes it okay?
Wait no I didn't do anything though I was doing the right
thing don't get angry at me
I'm I hope it was worth your time.
Now she's mad at me!
I was doing the right thing!
How are you not then?
Okay, you're gonna have to explain this, because I'm really
not getting it yet.
After a conversation in the taxi last night, I got a call
from Toad.
He said his son found a body.
We thought it was faith at the time.
What?
Getting her back here wasn't easy.
But hopefully we'll find something on her to help us track
down the killer.
Wait, that doesn't explain anything.
to figure out who she is I that's I should have been there I
should have been there snow I tried calling the business
office but there was no answer I couldn't find you or anyone
you knew where I was I was at the bar the whole time you
knew that huh snow what is it are you okay I'm glad you're
alive let's let's I'm glad you're not dead let's be nice to
her oh she noticed that me too i just want to get to the
bottom of this wait but i'm so confused what about the head
i just feel like what is it i just i feel responsible in a
way she looked just like me and maybe that's why she was
killed i don't think it's about you it's it's not your fault
i mean no it's not your fault but she looked just like me
that can't be a coincidence incidents we just have to find
out who did this and why she was clamored to look like me oh
so she was a it was a magic to look like I mean that's what
it is right so what's our next move we we keep working we
just keep doing what we do our jobs and I'm supposed to do
what sit around the business office twiddling my thumbs
waiting for the big bad that's not what I meant that's not
what I meant we've been what did you mean i told you i'm
tired of sitting around i'm not going i'm glad that if we
didn't tell him that i just want you to be she want to
change then i don't want him to like kick around i'm not
yours to lose i'm
sorry oh i think she just rejected us i know it's dangerous
but i'm not helpless i can take care of myself i've been
doing it for centuries
so freaked out last night he wouldn't tell us much even now
he just stops talking all together after a certain point
he's pretty shaken up though so try not to be too you know I
can handle it what to what oh it's the kid because he found
the body completed chapter 2 of episode 2
body.
TJ's over there.
I don't know if you want to talk to him first or after, but
let me know when you're ready to see the body.
Oh, they're looking in the mirror.
I want to be there.
Bufkin, do you have a second?
Of course, Miss Snow.
Oh, okay.
Uh...
We got our tarot cards again?
Well, it's in there, I wonder.
How mysterious.
We can rub the lamp.
I'm gonna rub the lamp for good luck.
What if one day it works?
That'd be crazy, no?
Rub-a-dub-dub!
One day I'll get my wish.
I still have the money.
That's so funny.
Yeah, I took that guy's antacids.
Antacids.
Maybe this has been harder on him than I thought.
Oh no!
He's so stressed his tongue.
Jimmy is upset.
Perfume bottle.
Who is this?
Snow on buffkin.
It's so tiny.
Snow's perfume.
Layla y'all.
And then the tarot cards.
We did these before though.
Did they change?
I wonder.
Pity these can't solve murders.
Oh, they're not there.
Oh, okay.
We got...
Oh.
That's appropriate.
The Three of Swords.
Another one?
The Moon.
Usually this is about deception or confusion.
But for me, well, who knows?
Deception or confusion?
I'm not completely convinced about Snow.
I'm not going to lie.
Like, I feel like that maybe was her and then someone is
glamored to be her.
We don't really have a...
a good reason not to believe that like she i don't know yet
i hope you can find what you're looking for the hermit yeah
i'm not quite convinced yet i'm not quite convinced let's go
talk to tj little guy oh why are you scared of me oh that's
enough mirra vanish cancel what the hell are you doing what
i was touch you nothing what's going on don't worry no i'm
done what why were you don't test me yeah don't test me
don't test me don't need to get a word up it ain't a big
deal tj oh little baby are you ready to talk to mr wolf yeah
Just say start at the beginning, or start at the beginning.
Just start from the beginning.
Yeah, yeah.
Go ahead, TJ.
Just tell us everything you know.
I go swimming at night sometimes.
In the river.
Aww.
I wasn't doing anything bad.
I promise.
We know.
Of course you weren't.
We know you weren't in trouble, little guy.
You're not in trouble.
Just tell me what happened.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Aww, he's so cute.
I was there.
Under the big blocks.
And I heard noisy feet.
And when I hear that, I'm supposed to go underwater and stay
real still and quiet.
That's right, son.
Oh.
Then I saw.
Then you saw?
I saw the lady.
Oh.
I'm going to comfort him.
Take your time.
The lady fell in.
but but she didn't have her head on oh my god wait that's so
traumatizing for him i thought she was gonna pull me down
too oh because because she had rocks on her feet and she
kept falling down in the dark parts cinder blocks tied to
her ankles is there more tj oh my god this poor kid is in
the water You know when people are lying?
I heard you could do that.
That's why you're the sheriff.
It's my job.
Yeah, part of my job is being able to tell when people are
lying.
I'm really good at it.
Oh, look at him smiling at him.
Oh!
Is there something else you want to say?
Please, don't be mad.
What is it, TJ?
I didn't stay under the water.
What?
I know I'm supposed to, but I was scared.
I don't blame him It sure is so funny I gave you very
specific rules You have to stay quiet Hey, you're not in
trouble You're not in trouble Look, Ellie's not Not this
time, Toad Yeah So you didn't stay underwater So did he see
who threw her in?
I don't know if anyone saw me But someone said stop Laughing
And then I was scared and I went under for as long as I
could.
Stop laughing.
Wait, you heard someone?
Yes.
Why didn't you tell us before?
Did you see anyone?
Did you see who it was?
No.
Uh, was someone laughing?
Did you hear anyone laughing?
No!
Uh, did you hear anything?
Uh, whose voice?
Do you know?
Do you know whose voice it was?
I don't know.
This poor kid.
I'm sorry After I came up again There was no one there And I
ran home, that's all I promise Oh, easy I want to go home
You can go, you can go Okay, you can go
Poor little guy Thank you, TJ Okay, son Good job, TJ You did
a good job, kid No, come on You will remember that.
How am I supposed to be a mean guy to that little TJ?
I want to get here.
That went about as well as I expected.
I think it went really good.
You want to go look at the body now?
Uh, in a minute.
In a minute.
Let's go check out the mirror.
When you're ready.
She's going to be talking to...
Uh, Bramble, what's this guy's name?
Bufkin.
Here, let's go check out the mirror.
See what we can snoop on.
What were they snooping on, I wonder?
Hey, mirror.
I do wonder maybe like his mom or something, right?
TJ's mom.
What was Toad watching?
What were you showing Mr. Toad and his son?
Cinderella selling shoes, Rapunzel, Rose, and of course
there's you.
And I can't help note that you did not rhyme.
Oh.
Do try to stick to the rules next time.
Yeah, I'll do that.
I like Mr. Toa was just like, Cancel!
Cancel!
Erase him!
How did he know about...
Show me tweedledum.
Where can I find tweedledum?
I guess we could have asked about Snow Wine.
And that piece of scum.
Yeah!
But I can't remember.
Did we have...
He's just...
He's like He's just He's aura farming in his car
Show me the woodsman The woodsman and I were fighting Now I
want to know Where he's hiding That could have been better
It works That's helpful Oh my god
Okay thank you I want to I mean, I guess...
I feel like Mr. Toad has nothing to do with any of this.
I'm just so curious about what he's doing.
But maybe we should have asked the mirror about Snow White.
I was too quick.
I'm so obsessed with Mr. Toad, I think, maybe.
Snow and Bufkin.
So, check out anyone who fits that profile.
You might start with Bluebeard.
Right away, Miss Snow.
Are you ready to examine the body now?
Uh, yes.
Yes.
yeah oh my goodness i almost forgot what's that
oh evidence come on was he giving us a moment was he giving
us some oh no this place is wild like what if we're doing
autopsy down here in like a dark souls dungeon what is going
on.
Is she even wearing her outfit?
Oh my gosh.
What if this is snow?
What if this really is her?
What if we're being deceived?
Wow.
I didn't realize I've never seen her face before now.
Are you okay?
Wait, how did you know that she looked just like you then?
I want to stay.
I'll be fine.
It's just a little strange.
That is very strange.
The glamour is so effective, it's invasive.
But just do what you need to do.
Can we remove the glamour?
Like, are we able to do that?
Check her mouth?
There might be a ribbon in there, like before.
No, but the girl was wearing the ribbon before, like on her
neck.
Anything?
Nothing.
Can you close her mouth?
I thought the girl with the ribbon before we knew she was
the donkey skin girl.
I thought she was the one where, like, uh...
Thanks.
Where if you take the ribbon off her neck, her head falls
off.
Did you guys ever read that creepy story?
I used to love it.
It scared me, but I loved it.
Wait, is this a different brooch?
That's weird.
I don't wear a brooch like that.
Maybe it really belonged to her.
not part of the glamour looks like something from the
homelands yeah ruffkin do you recognize these symbols no
nothing i've seen before now i kind of want to go back and
look and see if she was wearing a brooch looks just like
faith's dead it does actually it's like all choppy this time
do you think it was done by the same person hard to tell
that's so messed up
run more tests she got your perfume right how did she know
how do you know what perfume I wear you can't fool this nose
also I saw the bottle on your desk keep examining do you see
that could be a bruise a hickey oh la la so we gotta go look
for...
Oh.
I was gonna say we gotta go see what the symbol means, too.
Track marks?
She used Monday drugs.
Looks that way.
Oh!
I hear they only go for the legs if they've used up the
veins in their arms.
Or if they're trying to hide the marks.
I mean, you can check.
It means it's not a perfect match to your leg.
Unless... Oh!
Don't be maybe she was trying to compensate with that
perfume wait if the glamour is supposed to make her look
like me shouldn't it be concealing things like track marks
that brooch too why would it change everything else I've
never seen one this might be designed not to possible it's
designed not to right that's designed not to hide track
marks good point the witches upstairs know what they're
doing that's why they cost so much unless someone is making
glamours illegally oh it's not technically illegal miss it's
not encouraged for sure but there aren't any laws
specifically forbidding it so there's some sort of black
market for glamours i mean if they're so expensive i imagine
anyone with access to the proper books and training could
theoretically produce a glamour yet another thing to worry
about black market or not it's a pretty good match well i
was thinking maybe they were trying to like look at that the
buttons aren't exact either
maybe frame her for something by not hiding the marks you
know she's got something in her fist yeah her coat buttons
oh yeah because she's all interesting you're right these
buttons are wrong
what mind if i open her coat do you mind if i uh
pick me just let me do it is it gonna show is it get Am I
going to see dead boobies?
Oh.
Wow.
We.
Uh, it's not you.
It's not you, Snow.
It's just a body.
I...
Sorry, that took longer than expected.
Hello.
What have you found out?
Um, her glamour isn't perfect.
Or I'm not finished.
I haven't finished yet.
Yeah.
Well, get on with it then.
Okay.
We can't waste too much time.
pants the killer might be preparing another attack as we
speak yeah yeah we know maybe we should get more people on
the team sexy lingerie baby throw pocket let's check the
pockets check the pockets the perfume oh use this what is
that how did they know had the perfume with her looks like
someone picked it out for her so someone gave her
instructions she was like set up to die oh what is that i've
seen like this before oh it's definitely magic the witches
don't usually craft objects these days i don't think it's
wise to fool around with that it's some kind of black market
magic who knows what it could do scary have it looked at
just to make sure it isn't dangerous uh let's find out yeah
you may be right one way to find Here we go!
Yeah, play with it.
What?
There's something in here.
He's so paranoid.
How do we open it?
Scary baby.
Might want to stand back.
Might want to stand back if you're worried, Crane.
I'm gonna try to open it.
Yeah, let's see.
Something to do with these rings here.
Oh, all right.
All right.
That, yeah, the bush.
the booty okay it's a horse it's a deer a deer now what does
that mean oh it's hooray that's how she was able to look
like wait I wonder if the picture is like a little messed up
so that's why the buttons and things were off is that it's
your hair sniffing her hair she doesn't like that how'd they
get that thank you
someone must have taken this from my apartment I noticed it
was missing oh that's freaky I didn't think oh that's freaky
I had of Rose and me my sister and I don't talk much anymore
I wonder who Rose was Who did this, Big P?
Oh, I am.
Who is...
She's a troll?
You gotta be kidding me.
Oh my god!
Holy...
Holy shit.
Well, that helps explain the glamour.
Okay, I think this is the real snow.
Who is she?
That wasn't there before.
Who do you think she is?
Sorry!
I can't turn off the sound!
Should have left them all back in the homeland.
Maybe Holly knows.
The owner of the trip trap?
No, she looks a little...
Oh no.
What is it?
It's not Holly, it's her sister Lily.
Yeah, oh no!
Oh, that's right!
Oh my gosh, no!
We have to go tell Holly.
Right.
Oh no!
She might know something about this.
who only was seeing well certainly another troll we don't
know that we should go you can't go out there why not it's
too dangerous someone tried to kill you bigby you can't let
her go out there with you you'd be putting her life it's up
to snow is not in charge of me yeah no wants to come with me
i'm not gonna actually it'd be good if we kind of kept an
eye on her you know ready yeah wait but there was some stuff
no no no we're not ready to go yet no no no no wait the body
there There was something in her fist!
No, oh my gosh, I'm so sorry.
Thank you!
No, wait, there was some stuff in her fist!
Ah, he didn't get to look.
Dang it.
This whole thing is complete bullshit, and always has been.
I mean, what's his job, really?
To keep shit from reaching the woodlands.
Jack, I don't know where they are.
You're a bar.
You're supposed to have darts around.
And I normally do, but who knows where the fuck they went to
after...
Are they still complaining about me?
Hi!
I'm back.
Come on, Holly.
I need entertainment.
I think they're a little...
This'll do.
You think they're mad at me?
Oh, he's freaked.
We're fine.
Everything...
I feel really bad for her, though.
Oh, this is going to suck.
You can relax.
Okay.
Okay, I know.
Just relax.
I'm not here to start.
I'm having my oatmeal.
Sorry, guys.
Okay.
Miss White.
I heard you had kind of a strange morning.
It's been kind of a strange morning for everyone, I think.
Every time I see this guy, he seems to lose weight.
It's amazing.
It really is.
He loses weight and yet somehow keeps all the muscle.
Wolfie, my dear.
How are you?
Because, you know, we were just talking about you.
All of us.
I just need to talk.
Talk to Holly.
I just need to talk to Holly.
Privately.
All right.
Just give us a second first.
Who is this guy banned up there?
That guy right there.
Who is that?
Wait, it kind of looks...
Maybe he's like a Rumpelstiltskin or something.
Tweedle Dee was just here.
Oh, now you're talking.
He said it looked like Snow White.
What?
What the hell?
Rain.
Sorry.
Tweedle Dee said you arrested him for no earthly...
reason kept him locked in the cellar all fucking night he
said you tortured him which I don't know that seems like a
breach of I didn't do anything baby come on you can't be so
dumb as Jack find the off button now what is it with is it
like Jack and the beanstalk you think you and graner all
let's get a posse together when there's no one around but as
soon as the big bad wolf walks in your tails go between your
legs cat got your nerve what happened what happened I'm
tired of what of trouble Jack.
I'm sick and tired of trouble.
I don't want any Jack What big B look two fables are dead
now?
Yeah, we know friend's sister Holly's sister Holly's sister
has been missing for what a few days now?
Yeah, we need to get him out.
We need to get him out of here Hey, easy.
Oh fuck Jack, what'd I do?
Hey, hey mister get out of here.
Yeah, oh my god stalk jackie boy grant oh let me tell you i
mean he wasn't wrong though but we were just about he should
have let us talk we were about to get there actually have
there been any updates let's be gentle with her i don't know
how to say this to you holly the woman we found in the river
who was it oh you know who that was oh oh
god fucking damn it of course the dear princess Snow fucking
white is all safe and sound.
Where were you when we reported this weeks ago, huh?
Where are you when we ever fucking need you?
If you'd give one ounce of a shit about her, about any of
us, she might have been saved.
She might have been cared for.
She might have been...
Give her some room.
All right.
Clear out.
Give her some room.
I ain't leaving her with you.
is she okay i mean she's not okay but oh
holly get the fuck out of my bar i just want it should have
been you it should have been you and it wasn't
uh i i guess we don't know exactly if from her personal
effects.
I thought you might like to have it.
If Holly would, or not Holly, Holly's sister.
I didn't know she still had this.
The copper was from a dwarf mine.
It's very rare and very old.
We'll just watch.
It's quite lovely.
Let them do their thing.
Grim.
Yeah.
Take off for a bit, would you?
Are you sure?
Because we don't know if Holly's sister was working for them
and then was like set up or if like She was taken and then
put the glamour on and then, you know, like they use this.
We don't know if it was directed to her or whoever was given
the orders to make it look like Snow White, you know?
I don't know that much about her life.
Honestly, we didn't talk often.
Oh.
She was lost here in the city.
Why was Lily glamoured?
Who might know more?
Did she have any friends?
Anyone who could tell us what she might have been doing.
Yeah, I should be a target.
I don't know about her friends.
She hung around where she worked mostly.
Well, where did she work?
She was hooking to pay down debt.
It ain't me up to see her that way.
Eventually, the only people she owed were at her work.
You know, that shithole club, the pudding and pie.
The pudding and pie!
It's delicious.
The orange energy with all this fucking fees.
It's a crock of shit.
That's how they kept her in the store.
Oh, so she worked at the club.
Holly it's okay if it's too much we don't have to do this
Georgie hmm what do you know about him yeah we can just go
talk to him we've got a lead maybe we can take it from here
Lily anything else you can tell us you can tell us yeah I
don't think so like I said we didn't talk much but that's
all right you've been more than helpful is she where is she
She's at the business office.
She's taken care of.
I'm gonna have to go down there and get her.
Fuck.
Please, we can handle the funeral arrangements.
No, no, it's a kind of...
It's a formality with trolls.
We burn our dead by sunrise or...
I don't know.
Her body is evidence though, uh...
Fuck your soul up.
Holly, Lily's the best evidence we have right now.
We can't surrender her body till I know it can't help the
case anymore.
We refuse to give Holly the body.
This is really important.
to me and the investigation is important to everyone look
why don't you come down with me to the business office and
we'll see I mean I didn't get to finish investigating I
think she likes her that club I'll go down there now I'm
going to the club baby when you come back to the office
please try to make more of an effort with her have I not
been just do it for me it makes everything easier oh my
goodness everybody is always assuming that i am acting the
worst i mean i did do that but but they provoke me
completed chapter three of episode two
they provoke me am i not but a man and a wolf am i not but
the wolf man cash and hotel The pudding and the pie.
What a great name.
Who's that?
Oh, she's got a ribbon on her neck.
Is that like their uniform?
Oh, Sheriff, what a nice surprise.
I'm not sure I've seen you here before.
You're always welcome, of course.
I'm a friend of Georgies.
Where is he?
Uh-oh.
Oh, she called out my my yes.
Oh, she's here.
Come on
She's got the ribbon on her neck I should warn you that
Georgie does not like to be bothered when he's working And
he's in kind of a mood right now.
I mean more so than usual.
I have a way with people I have a way with people So I've
heard ah Yeah Yep oh my gosh we're at the club wait are we
gonna see club shenanigans i should welcome to the pudding
and pie thank you cater to the diverse taste of the fable
community your pleasure is our pleasure did you know lily
your desires are our desires did you know lily She worked
here My lips are sealed.
That's the you'd better ask Georgie.
Everybody keeps saying that my lips are sealed
We're seeing club shenanigans.
Oh Foxy What do you think you're doing?
You look like you're trying to take a shit Who's gonna want
that?
Nice place nice place you have a sense of humor that's good
good life oh we're censoring that's good let's work for me
how how gosh i was gonna say how much could i censor as soon
as he walked how many times do i have to say it you're
supposed to turn the clients on that's your job you want
them to fear look at the mermaid oh hello sorry oh it's you
we're closed Georgie oh my goodness I've got a few questions
I got a few questions imagine my excitement Georgie is
awfully suspicious right now there's so many things
connecting him back to what do you want then you here for a
little taste oh tell come back after midnight maybe I can
hook you up or uh knowing you this is probably not quite
your style what do you mean knowing you'd prefer someone who
can take a bit of a beating tell me you prefer a stationary
target or one that will put up a five I'm not here for that
oh I'm not here for that just stopped in for the chips I
mean isn't that why people go to Hooters for the wings so
corny I love it though no seriously I love it Corny.
I love this feel the thunder on that poster back then.
Okay, all right, Sheriff.
Just fucking with you.
Look, I know why you're here.
Do you?
Are you sure?
Listen, Sheriff.
Around here, we can't afford to wait for you and your swanky
pals to take an interest.
We have to look out for each other.
When shit happens, I hear about it.
Especially if it concerns my livelihood.
Uh-huh.
In that case, I assume you knew Lily was glamour.
Of course she was, you duff git.
She was a troll.
No.
I mean glamour to look like another fable.
Yeah?
Well, so what?
Who gives a toss?
People get up to all kinds of...
This is not illegal, though.
Right.
It's her own business.
Is this some great strategy to get me to incriminate myself?
Yeah, just keep talking.
This is exactly what I would expect from a thug like you.
Storm in, throw around a bunch of accusers.
Try to scare people, but you've got fuck all to back it up.
And we're all just meant to jump anytime the wolf shows it
to him.
Show him the glamour box.
It must be something, you know.
Nothing to back it up?
Well, what the fuck is this then?
Get that out of my face.
I found it on Lily's body, and it's definitely a back alley
job.
Where did she get it?
Yeah.
You've got this all wrong.
If Lily was doing a special glamour, it wasn't for me.
For fuck's sake.
want that kind of eat imagine she was glamoring as snow
clients big bit maybe one of them was into it a lot of
fucked up people in fable town like who try looking in the
mirror what anyway now what to do with me go on then i am
i'm gonna turn it off You're gonna hit me go ahead.
That's what you want to do.
Who hired her?
Oh, oh No, fuck Yo, take your sad fucking face when I can't
see it Bloody bastard fucking shit You proud of yourself
mate.
Proud of your little mess.
Oh, not his boom box.
No, fuck's sake You good Oh, fuck up, Hans.
Not Hans!
I think Hans might.
Hans isn't.
Hold on a minute.
Hans, is it?
Hans just cleans up and provides a little muscle when we
need it.
He's not going to know anything about the girls and their
clients or any of that.
No one knows.
Uh-huh.
What do you mean no one knows?
Somebody has to know.
Discretion is our guarantee, right?
And the way we guarantee that is that no one knows anything
they don't have to know.
Including me, I cover my...
He looks sad.
He looks like he knows something.
Oh, this guy knows something.
Why not look it up?
What's that?
Isn't there a little book with all the stuff about the girls
and all that written?
Why not looking up?
Fucking moron.
Show me.
Why not looking up?
There is no book.
And as for you, Hans, we need to work on your communication
skills.
Not the crowd control stick.
Oh my gosh, the Yahweh paddle.
Where to start?
Hey, that's my personal property.
I'm gonna smash the boom box.
Sure, go ahead.
Do what comes naturally.
You unbelievable prick.
Yeah, that was so unnecessary.
I know.
I want that book.
Looks at the very dramatically.
Looks at the cigarette machine.
Ance is confused again.
I don't think he is.
I don't think he is at all.
Don't even think about it.
I could tell.
I'm going to destroy the TV.
I've got to do it.
Tell me where the book is.
Come on, Georgie.
Hand it over, Wally.
That's nothing to do with you.
Hand it over.
Why, I still care.
We're still time for you to just cough it up.
I'm sorry, Sheriff, but there's no Andy Magic book with
everything you want to know jotted down inside.
I sincerely wish there was.
Maybe it would get you off me back.
well well what's this yeah looks like a floor safe i
wouldn't know it was here when we moved in i don't have a
key to it this guy come on fuck's sake i've got to open up
in a few hours everybody's so stubborn come on give me the
book you don't want me to hurt you georgie georgie i got
hands and i got a yowie paddle we get it everyone's guilty
we fucking get it Jesus you're killing me give me the neon
sign of the mermaid people are dead two women are dead then
quit being a bloody idiot okay I got to smash something else
there's nothing there for okay goodbye DJ boo oh my gosh
this is a dance club What the hell am I supposed to do
tonight while the girls on stage?
Ah, Monica, Kazoo, Whistle-A-Happy-Tune?
Fucking unbelievable.
Bloody come on, then.
Ah, we got him.
We got him.
Fucking trash my business over this bullshit.
Protector of the able town my ass.
We broke everything that makes noise.
Anything that could have a fun time.
It's nothing near that'll tell you anything.
It's a kick to the balls for me and my club so we can be
happy about that.
Not the dollar bills.
You could have, if you had just given this to me in the
first place, and you would have had something, you know.
Here, this is Lily's last entry.
So tell me, Georgie.
Who's this Mr. Smith?
Mr. Smith.
Oh, dear.
I'm afraid it might be a fake name, Bigby.
Sounds good.
Secret is sort of how this all works.
Even Anse knows that.
What's 207?
Room number?
I don't fucking know.
Millimeters, maybe.
Don't bullshit me, Georgie.
Come on, Georgie.
Your book, your girl.
Yeah, does he not care that they're dead?
I give them a stage, I give them music, I provide an erotic
venue to attract and retain clients.
But let's be clear on something.
Uh-oh.
The girls make the arrangements with their clients, not me,
the girls.
They're the ones with the Mr. Smiths, and Joneses, and Mr.
X-types.
Mr. X.
Whatever happens outside the club, that's on them.
I log the business, take my cut, and I'm out.
Now, I've had quite enough of you and your bullying.
Oh, he disappears to make a complaint.
I got the job done, though, didn't I?
Kind of.
Hello.
Business office.
I could get him to hang up the phone.
I'm going to take that, and I'm going to hang it up.
Oh, I'm looking at him, but not really.
Yeah, that's right.
Georgie.
Anything else in here?
We got some small...
I could take his money.
I'm pocketing the money.
Roll of bills?
I can't be greedy.
Oh.
Okay, the game decided for me.
I don't give a rat sass about that.
Just fuck off and fetch him from me.
The game decided for me.
All right, let's go to see what she has to say.
No, I don't want to.
Surely she's put on some clothes at this point now, right?
We got some cosmetics on the floor.
Not the lipsticks on the floor.
Ew.
What's that there?
A note.
Ew.
I'm still holding the cash.
Thanks for covering for me tonight.
Let's talk before you go over to the apartment.
Lily.
Looks like they both saw one of Lily's clients.
I'm still holding the cash.
Cubby?
Oh, Lily's?
And this is Faith's cubby?
Jewelry box.
Yeah, someone...
They've been trying to find whatever Faith had.
Makeup case.
That one also.
Oh!
Broken open.
But there isn't even a lock.
Someone was in a hurry.
Someone was aggressive about it.
Excuse me?
I don't see you there.
Oh, yeah?
I don't remember ever seeing you here before.
Well, I'm here now.
I'm here now.
I'm still holding the cash.
You're trying to place me.
They used to call me the little mermaid.
Once upon a time.
What do they call you now?
Whatever makes them happy.
I'm eating my own meal still.
My name is Nerissa.
Oh.
Well, Nerissa, I've got some questions.
No!
Nerissa!
You'll have to find those yourself.
I thought you were a raven.
Not a mermaid!
207.
Does the number 207 mean anything to you?
I assumed it was a room number.
But where?
Yeah.
We can't talk about work.
This is a murder case.
I mean, can't.
Wow.
these lips are sealed discretion is our guarantee it's
people keep saying that yeah people keep using those phrases
what does it mean this is what I need to know about Lily's
last entry who's mr.
Smith where's room 207 I have to know it's like an accessory
on me now lips these lips are I wonder is it like magic
Sheriff Wolf, would you like to make an appointment with me?
Okay.
What would I need to do?
I need 150.
It's not good to be short.
Oh.
Uh, give her all the money?
I don't know how much we have actually.
Wait, no, my dollar bill accessory!
Oh, no, I still have it.
Good.
Am I short?
It's okay.
Wait here for a second.
Put it in the pie posters even.
Wow.
Yeah, oh.
Are we going to room 207?
Oh, we're going to room 204.
Is it occupied?
You'll think of something.
I'll pay the person with his sweet, sweet dollar.
This is where they met.
Enjoy your stay.
I hope you find what you're looking for.
Ah, cool.
So we get the location now because we made the appointment.
The appointment.
Let's complete a chapter 4 of episode 2.
What's going on here?
Oh, oh.
Oh, it's like literally right next door.
It's so...
Hello, officer?
Uh-huh.
I thought it was gonna be in some like, really like hidden
away place, but it's literally just two steps away.
Okay.
I already have a room.
Someone gonna yell at me for smoking in here?
I can't believe you could just smoke anywhere.
Smile, you're on camera!
Let's see.
Can I get a soda?
Yeah, I shall kill you.
Okay.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
That will kill you.
Worms or anything like the lobby?
They should cut their rates.
Actually, though.
Wait, who are the...
This cat...
You should probably repair that.
The cat...
Missing cat posters are everywhere, but there's also missing
people.
Uh...
Uh, let's...
Uh, hello?
Anybody here?
Ring a ling!
Wanted by the hour.
or for the whole night oh oh i work here okay i work the
front desk it's to help pay rent so now you know oh i know i
should have told somebody but beast would lose his mind if
you knew i won't say anything he wants to do right by me and
he he just couldn't handle it if he knew i had to do this so
we don't get evicted okay well i don't care i could honestly
not care less about this yeah what you want you know i don't
know why i ever expected anything from you what beast you
saw me when i expressly asked you not to and now you say you
don't even care uh uh well um anyways i'm just explaining
what i'm doing here sorry so what are you doing here i've
got a room oh you have a key someone else was murdered last
night i heard a victim was worked at the pudding and pie
lily she uh come around here ever oh oh yes the the troll i
did see her yeah i mean you know we never really spoke but
she came off a tad intimidating uh did you ever see lily
with anyone ever see lily with someone here maybe on a job a
job sometimes but nobody I've recognized I haven't worked I
mean let's stop the people from glimmering themselves too so
nobody recognizes you know that's all we get here Smith's
Jones or Johnson's I think the last ones are jokes have you
seen snow here have you seen snow white down here or maybe
somebody glimmered is her you know it's funny I did see
someone who I thought looked a lot like her She didn't say
anything when she saw me, even though she knew that I saw
her.
Oh.
I just assumed it wasn't snow and went about my business.
That's so messed up.
Hey, can you, like, recreate yourself to look like this
princess?
Does you know Faith?
Ever meet a girl named Faith?
Or just maybe hear that name?
I might have.
I don't know.
By the end of the night, it's kind of a blur with all the
names.
Brandy, Amber, Heather...
You're not Tweedledee.
I talked to Tweedledee earlier today.
He mentioned you in passing.
Oh yeah.
That's right, he did say that, didn't he?
I took out a loan.
For back pay.
It was like our third notice.
And ever since then, those annoying freaks have been
pestering me for the money, plus interest.
Why take out a loan from those two?
Yeah, they suck.
It was from the crooked man.
Crooked man.
You don't know how desperate I was, Bigby.
I had nowhere else to go.
Look, if this ever happens again, come see me or snow first,
all right?
I tried.
Thanks.
Wait.
It'll be better if anyone sees you that they at least see
you with me, so they know that I didn't let you just wander
around by yourself.
But I have a room key.
Oh, well, I don't have a lady friend with me, though.
Five minutes, please.
We'll see, beauty.
Just be ready to act like I'm trying to kick you out.
That won't be hard.
Listen, Bigby, I assume you'll be filing some kind of an
official report or something, which is fine.
It's just that I was wondering if I need to be in it.
Do you have to mention my name?
I mean, it's not like Beast would ever see you report.
It's just...
That's fine.
We don't need to mention her.
I don't think we need to mention her, though.
Unless I have to write down the better.
Thanks.
I appreciate it.
Do I hear things happening?
Well, here we are.
Which one was it?
I can't loosen!
Oh, I know what, I know.
Uh, uh, three little monkeys jumping on the bed.
One jumps off and bumps his head.
No, Itigo Icats, what are you doing here?
Is there anything going on here?
Wait, we need to get into 207, no?
We don't care about 204.
Let's go to 207.
Hello?
Anybody in here?
207.
I'm going in.
You have keys to these rooms?
I thought you had a key.
Not to this one.
Hold on, Bigby.
I can't just let you go into any room you want.
Seriously.
What if someone found out?
This is where Lily was.
I don't care.
It's a murder.
investigation why don't i get a warrant 207 but i this is
the room lily was in fine oh my goodness i mean i'm kind of
curious weird oh this key is supposed to open every room in
the building it's not working beauty oh no how is he here
how could you do this to me no sweetie no wait a minute how
could you do this we've been together through everything i
took care of you i love not what you think please oh you're
cheating on me with him no no beast i promise i'm not i'm
helping him that's all i'll bet i'm sure you help each other
just great i'm on a case this is a murder investigation
she's helping me stop lying to me what the is wrong with you
she's my wife i told you where she was There's nothing going
on.
The Jarama!
I guess I finally see you for who you are.
What's that supposed to mean, huh?
You said you saw her that night.
Just...
Just talk to your wife!
I have to leave me out of this.
I'm eating my food!
What the hell do you think you're doing?
You aren't even listening to me!
I was eating my oatmeal!
Oh dang.
Not the pipe!
I pressed W though.
Oh, I still got hit.
Ah!
Holy!
I mean, he'll recover, right?
He's a fable.
He'll recover.
Don't hurt him.
Ah, he's had enough, huh?
This is... Oh no, he's gonna hit me though.
Oh, Charles.
Hey, could you tell your husband to stop hitting me then
too?
You ruined everything!
I didn't do anything!
Oh, that's one way to get into the room.
Awesome.
Oh, there's blood in here.
Uh-oh.
Shit, Big B.
What have you done?
What?
He's crying blood.
I told you it was our...
Look what you did to the door!
You can't just act like this whenever you- Stand back!
You don't want to see this.
Whoa.
Oh, it's like an actual sacrificial...
Well, the door's open now!
We got the door open.
Oh my god.
Don't touch anything.
Is this... who's this?
Lily met her client here.
Mr. Smith, whoever he is.
And then...
Must have happened right here.
Oh, he said it was a murder investigation!
Yeah.
I was on ship last night.
night on shift beauty what i'm not a prostitute you idiot
who rented work the front desk do you remember who rented
this room last night i don't think anyone did not last night
maybe they have it long term i don't know how am i supposed
to know it just yeah what do you mean how am i supposed to
know you work the front desk how is that even possible
there's so much blood yeah she got the capitated people out
of the hallway i need you to be sure no one comes in here
this is a crime scene okay but just do what he says I'll
explain later okay all that fight well the fighting when we
worked out we were able to push the door down big B what
could do something like this that's exactly what I'm about
to try to find out so silly okay we got a cassette player do
all the rooms have these same clocks with the built-in
cassette player i think so yes does it have anything in it
no yikes looks like she was lying down when she was killed
flowers were already here how do you know that blood pattern
also i'd say the body was dragged off the foot of the bed
there the body jesus you could say she poor girl i just okay
you're like hindering my investigation ma'am please I don't
need your commentary on everything I don't know I feel like
the flowers came second because wouldn't they then be like
so coated and splattered and blood it's nice pretty though
storybook oh wait they're they're marked oh it's a book
about snow white or about the Monday version of her story
about her yeah Fuji red delicious Empire what kind of apples
were they beautiful
that's in German oh was she breathing glass coffin this is
the part where she's in a deep sleep but they think she's
dead huh what's it mean why mark the page where she's
sleeping Obsessed with death, the bed matches the coffin.
It does.
I think he made up the bed to match the coffin.
I think he's, like, obsessed with this kind of...
He'd have had Lily lie down just like this.
You mean just before?
In the story, that's when someone comes to kiss her.
A kiss of death!
That's when Mr. Smith...
This is creepy.
The coffin and the weird fixation on snow.
Yeah!
The hell is wrong with this guy.
Oh...
Nine.
Oh.
Let's wait, what do we got here?
God.
A cigarette?
It's a Huff and Puff.
I thought you were the only one who smoked that crap brand.
Apparently not.
I mean, there's Huff and Puff's...
Wait, there's the perfume right there, too.
But there's Huff and Puff machines all over the place.
He brought wine.
Romantic.
Poor girl.
Look at that.
For my arrival.
Wait, what's in here first, though?
It looks like a costume, like a snow white costume.
Someone's been rough with this dress.
It's torn.
Oh, no.
Oh, my God!
She must have been wearing it.
He killed her and then, and then he took it back off.
no there's no blood on it yeah it must have been torn some
other time what what are you thinking he likes it rough it
looks like snow costume yeah yeah dress is the one in the
book about snow I think Smith was dressing you connected the
evidence to recreate the snow from the book what's the tape
though I'm so curious it fits for my arrival out scenes from
the book that poor girl I probably just needed the money she
could have been anyone how did she wind up here i mean not
exactly here but just how does a person georgie took
advantage we can't know the answer to that every situation
is different yeah like how lily came to work at the place i
mean we don't know that she must have been so scared oh
let's play the cassette i mean i do want to blame georgie
but
I was about to say is it gonna be like bird sounds and stuff
oh my god it really is that she's gonna be lying on the bed
Bigby this I think I heard this music last night it was
playing pretty loudly for a while and then stopped in the
middle I didn't think this guy's got a freaky you hear all
kinds of things around here and I guess I've already gotten
used to blocking them out could have covered up the sound of
the murder
Oh my god.
Maybe she didn't see it coming.
How crazy.
Um, how do I find out who rents the room?
Yeah.
How can I find out who rented this room?
Find whoever has the key.
I'm pretty sure this one must be held long term.
Yeah, right?
We don't keep a register or anything.
This place is intentionally kind of anonymous.
I keep hearing that.
right man really making our investigation tough um anything
else you can tell me is there anything else you can tell me
about last night anything that sticks out in your mind the
music is killing me it just seemed like every other night
does that's exactly what's bothering me from now on i'll
just be down there imagining this oh you better not be
hiding anything better not find out you're hiding something
for me about all this what the hell is wrong with you i'm
not involved in this please just do whatever you need to do
and let's get out of here
damn it get it together beauty be strong
i don't think there's anything on this side i think we can
examine the tape one more time
can i stop it no okay I just noticed my dollar bill is gone
now.
Uh, there's nothing else.
Nothing in the trash.
God.
Uh, oh, there we go.
Oh, there's an apple?
Oh!
Do you smell something?
No, just apple.
Is it poisoned?
Maybe like a sleep?
Oh, no, there's more?
What?
What now?
murder makes him hungry it's like the apple she was eating
when he attacked it's got a single bite taken out of it like
in snow story yeah no do you think it was poisoned it wasn't
i'd have smelled that okay i think it's just a prop it's
here because they were this is a crazy fetish of course that
makes perfect sense okay my point snow white i'm here to
awaken you point It all goes together like you said.
This creep put that girl in a snow white dress and recreated
the whole story from the book with the apple and the deep
sleep and everything.
The deep sleep that you never wake up from because you're
decapitated.
So he planned it all out.
He had all the details noted down.
Only then when it comes time to kiss her and wake her up.
Yeah.
I hope you're just about through.
I don't really want to stay in here any longer.
I'm surprised he didn't smell the blood from, like, outside
the door, to be honest, because that's a lot of blood.
An envelope.
Oh, the music is so loud.
Oh!
Are those pictures of the dead girl?
Worse, maybe?
How do you know?
I'm in this one.
Oh!
taken last winter oh no bigby this kind of stocking it
doesn't just stop by itself trust me I know about this
firsthand he'll keep trying to get closer and closer his
stand-in for snow is gone now so the next step closer is
snow but what is it crane no
Oh, this weasel.
Oh, this weasel and weasel.
Oh, my god!
No, stinking way.
Completed episode two!
He could be after you now.
Good.
I am dying to get my hands on that disgusting weasel.
That's what I called him!
I never should have...
Nice to be to you ever.
Who took that photo?
Really starting to like you, Sheriff.
You're not afraid to be a complete bastard.
Yeah, I know.
Obviously, there will have to be some changes.
Hello, Bigby.
Take care of it, Bigby.
Or I'll take care of it for you.
Wait a second, though.
We did see, like, Bigby in the...
Yeah, this one.
Of course, Bigby.
Yeah.
We saw this preview, that preview, and we didn't get, it
didn't happen.
Oh, how did you respond to Crane about Snow's death?
You and 68% of players sympathized with him.
I never should have.
Oh, I never should have sympathized.
Well, I'm sympathizing with Bigby.
Oh, I never should have sympathized with Ukraine.
How did you treat the murder suspect?
62% of players persuaded him to talk.
Yeah.
Oh, did you let Snow come with you to the trip trap?
You and 90% of players let her make her own decision.
Yeah.
How did you handle Georgie Porgy?
You and 69.9% of players didn't hit Georgie.
I speak.
I'm too good, you know.
Did you keep punching Beast when he was down?
You and 77% of players opted not to talk.
hippies the second time and then yeah okay okay so we're
pretty much in the majority of how most people are playing
dang i never should have sympathized with this guy he sucks
he sucks he sucks
unless it's a setup i mean now that we know that you could
just glamor as anybody it's that kind of What if he was set
up?
Everybody's being set up.
Nobody is safe, maybe.
Wowie.
That was quite the episode.
I still am upset that I didn't check what was in Lily's hand
when investigating her body, but maybe I guess it wasn't
just...
I guess it wasn't that important.
because they let us continue without it.
But I'm just curious what it was.
What if it was like a petal or something?
Imagine if it was like a flower petal or something.
That would have been...
That would have been crazy.
Like the purple flower.
He killed the mirror.
So sad.
I'm very curious where this will go.
because we still have so many episodes left.
Like, we're not even halfway through.
We still have three episodes left.
But...
And then Bluebeard, I don't know.
What if it's, like, Crane being set up to then someone take
over his position, you know, and then start ruling the town
as mayor?
It's hard to say, right?
The thing with Snow White is crazy.
The music is so funny.
The ambiance.
The nature ambiance.
Ooh, la la.
I mean, also, where did he get the flowers from?
Because why don't we, like, question the florist or
something, too?
Like, who?
Who brought...
Who bought those flowers?
You know?
That's another lead, potentially.
Maybe.
I don't know.
I'm thinking like a detective here, I think.
Well, I guess we'll check it out next time.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
Hang out with me.
I hope you guys are enjoying the story as much as I am
because I love me a good mystery, baby.
Thank you guys so, so much.
And we will continue into today.
chapter no sorry episode three next time thank you so much
everybody have a good day have a good night and i'll see you
later bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye